c'est non ma voiture elle ne fait pas de
bruit et on est bien dedans je ne
pourrais pas en dire autant de toutes
les femmes que j'ai conduite sur les
chemins incongru de la vie points aux
restes toi ma voiture
tu n'as pas besoin que je te conduise
pour être mienne points je te fait
conduire par un autre ça me permet
d'être assis plus près de dieu à la
place du mort dans sa grande carcasse
noir de corbillard où nous filons à ton
beau fermer points et huron 1 940 et je
compte les boutons d'or à flore à fleur
de bitume sans être importunés par les
exigences cabalistiques des panneaux
routiers autoritaire heureux à l'idée
que je finirais ma vie sans avoir jamais
connu l'humiliation de dire bonjour un
moniteur d'auto-école point m'attire ma
caisse mon américaines comme l'année à 8
mois en r tué huit cylindres en v mon
âme inquiète se rassurent de ses
certitudes
imperturbable comme sont imperturbables
le cycle des saisons
la poussée des seins chez les enfants
femelles et le sourire confiant des
démocrates points
pierre d
[Musique]
c'est étonnant non